Two years ago,
on January the
sixth, our democracy was attacked.
No other way of saying
the U.S.
Capitol was breached,
which had never happened
before in the history
of the United States of America,
even during the Civil War.
A violent mob of insurrectionists
assaulted law enforcement vendor lives,
sacred halls,
hunted down elected officials,
all for the purpose,
an attempt
to overthrow the will of the people
and usurp the peaceful transfer of power.
All of it,
all of it was fueled
by lies about the 2020 election.
But on this day, two years ago,
our democracy held because we the people,
as the Constitution refers
us, we the people did not flinch.
We the people endured.
We the people prevailed.
And on this day of remembrance,
joined by the vice
president of the second gentleman
and all of you.
We honor a remarkable group of Americans
who embodied the best
before during and after
January the sixth 2021.
For the first time in
my presidency,
I am bestowing
the presidential citizen's medal.
One of our nation's highest
civilian honors
recognizes, quote,
citizens of the United States of America
who have performed
exemplary deeds of service
for their country
or their fellow citizens, end of quote.
In a few moments and a few moments,
the full citation
of their exemplary
deeds will be read by military aid.
But this is who these people,
these extraordinary Americans
are heroic law enforcement officers.
As Congressman Bennie Thompson
said, a man of immense character
and honor himself
eloquently said about these officers.
He said, quote,
You held the line that day.
And what was on the line
was our democracy.
And history will remember your names
and history will remember your names,
remember your courage,
remember your bravery, and remember
your extraordinary commitments
to your fellow Americans.
That's not hyperbole.
That's a fact. That's a fact.
Folks, history also
going to
remember your instincts
to respond, to do something as you did.
And as we all watched.
This is the irony of it all.
All of America watched it, watched it on
television, saw it repeated and repeated.
In the past months,
we've heard
you testified to the nation
about what happened that day.
What you were thinking of
at the time was happening,
what you're thinking now,
the threats,
the violence, the savage
loss of what happened,
the trauma all real.
And it's not exaggeration to say
America owes you,
owes you all.
I really mean this
debt a debt of gratitude
when we can never fully repay
unless we live up to what you did,
live up to what you did.
And what you did was truly consequential
and a joke.
If I can hold for
a second and just say to you,
the impact, what happened on July
six had international repercussions
beyond what I think
any of you can fully understand.
The first meeting I had of what they call
the G-7, the seven leading
economies in the world, democracies.
I sat down was in February.
I was in England,
and I sat next to the president
of France, across
from the chancellor, from Germany, etc.
And I said, America's back.
Know what the response was as a joke?
For how long
for how long
And I just sat there and looked
and I believe
it was the prime minister of Italy.
He said,
but I can't remember for certain
which of the 76 said it
What would you think, Mr. President,
if tomorrow
you woke up and
you have a headline in the press
saying that in the British Parliament,
a mob
had come down the hall, broken down
the doors of the House of Commons,
police officers were killed or died
the place was vandalized
in order to overthrow the election
of the Speaker of the House.
A Prime Minister's election
Think about it.
Think about it
or we think if we heard that news today,
any other
the leading democracy in the world
through this,
some folks
these people and the people
representing those
who couldn't be here
because they gave their lives for this
did is incredibly consequential.
It's just that's not political talk.
That's a historical fact.
Folks,
I fellow Americans,
I want you to give one round of applause.
Again, today's recipients
of the Presidential Citizen's
Medal Patriots
who have performed
exemplary deeds
in the service of this great nation.
Let me close with this.
82 years ago, on this very day in 1941,
President Franklin
Roosevelt delivered his
State of the Union address
that became known
as his famous for freedom speech
as he defined America's
place in the world.
He reminded
the American people
of, quote, the strength
from the things which have been done
to make his people
conscious.
Of their individual stake
in the preservation
of democratic life in America.
Things that have
toughened the fiber of our people,
renewed their faith
and strengthened
the devotion to the institutions
we make ready to protect and of quote.
80 years ago,
after that speech, on this day
two years ago, we were reminded
about the most fundamental of things
democracy itself.
As I've said
before, we face an inflection
point in our nation's history.
On January 6th is a reminder
that there's nothing
guaranteed about our democracy.
Remember learning
to undergraduate school, high school
that every generation
is required to earn it.
Defend it. Protect it.
I was a senator for a long time.
I was vice president, then president.
I have to tell you,
I began to think,
looking back on it,
that it was just permanent
in the United States.
Just was eternal.
Nothing would happen
That's why I was so pleased
to see Democrats and Republicans
work together
to pass the Electoral Count Reform Act
that I just signed into law
to protect the will of the people.
In the past, peaceful transfer of power
and defending
and protecting our democracy
also means
that despite our differences of opinion,
we must say clearly
with the united voice
that there's no place 900 place
in America for voter intimidation,
zero never end political violence there.
Completely contrary
to the notion of democracy.
You know,
America is a land of laws and not chaos.
A nation of peace and not violence.
We're not a land of kings
and dictators, autocrats and extremists,
as we see in today's honorees.
We're a nation of we the people
that toughen our fiber,
renew our faith,
and strengthen our cause.
Just remember who in God's name we are
who are the United States of America?
Manager for the United States of America.
And there's nothing
there is nothing.
There has never been a single thing.
We've set our minds
that we've been failed to accomplish.
There's nothing beyond our capacity
If we act together,
remember who in God's name we are.
So God bless you all.
And may God protect our troops.
And may God protect
those who stand watch over our democracy.